awesome
thanks CJ anyone have any other job
announcements or anyone looking for a
job that wants to come say hi awesome
this has been a lot of fun too to start
presenting here's the part where I say
I'm definitely going to post the slides
on my blog tonight and you go check
tonight and they're not there and you
check tomorrow and they're not there
next week next month in three months
you're gonna get tired of waiting you're
gonna email me in six months I'm gonna
reply and say no I'm definitely gonna
post them on my blog tonight and I will
never post them on my blog which is why
you can go to Robert's org right now and
click on presentations right here scroll
down to our meetup right here post
jQuery and you can pop open the slides
that we're gonna look at right now feel
free to get ahead all of these blue
links are links that will click you off
into the details about that which is
really cool so while you're here on my
blog click on about me and you'll get to
this page and this talks a little bit
about things that I've done I have a
Microsoft MVP I'm a friend of red gate
hazy give camp is really exciting a Z
give camp brings volunteer developers
together with charities who otherwise
couldn't afford software services we
sell form teams Friday after work Sunday
afternoon we deliver completed projects
sleep is optional caffeine provided if
you're ever in Phoenix come look us up
because AZ give camp is really really
cool
I worked on sequel server source control
basics that's a lot of fun - chapter 8
it's a cool book I was a core
contributor to gulp in version 2 in
version 3 so that's kind of where I cut
my teeth in JavaScript which was pretty
fun some of the user groups that I'm
familiar with associated with I helped
with the Phoenix angular meetup and also
the south east valley net user group
I said south east valley dotnet user
group earlier and somebody said is that
by Hollywood South East Valley in
Phoenix it's actually in Chen
Arizona so that's pretty cool whoo-hoo
so one of the things I'm particularly
proud of is I replied to an episode of
the dotnet Rock's podcast they read my
comment on the earth they sent me a mug
woohoo I got a mug so enough about me
let's talk about jQuery so we talked
about this guy jQuery jQuery the write
more do less JavaScript library jQuery
was invented in a in a time when the web
was really hard to use and jQuery was
great in paving over the differences
between browsers making JavaScript much
more approachable and it was great
in its day so jQuery came out in January
2006 and I I grant that you know some of
us learned it yesterday
but it started in January 2006
so in January 2006 the the browser's of
choice were Internet Explorer 7 Netscape
8 Firefox 2 we're up to like Firefox 50
something right Safari - those were kind
of the browser's of the days anyone
still support IE 7 this is the era that
jquery was built for so what else
happened in 2006 well YouTube is one
year old Yelp is two years old
myspace is three awesome way to go
myspace some other websites that were
really popular in 2006
apparently shockwave games were all the
rage tail ranked comm was a great news
aggregator Deadspin comm was a great
sports has anyone ever heard of any of
these Zipcar yeah I think I've heard of
shockwave
yeah this was 2006 so the state of the
web in 2006 we had this really
inconsistent browser experience each
browser implemented the dom differently
javascript
engine was clogged in great detail and
very carefully and although the
JavaScript engines were very consistent
across the browsers but the Dom the way
that we interacted with the page was
very very different
so javascript is hard
well JavaScript wasn't hard the Dom was
hard but javascript was hard and so what
jQuery brought us was this really
elegant simple paradigm of how to deal
with javascript in the browser it paved
over all of these browser
inconsistencies and it gave us a really
really simple experience to be able to
target any browser which is wonderful
that's a great and noble goal it did a
great job it's on you know 90 some odd
percent of the websites and you know now
we've gotten to that point where it did
a great job in browsers have caught up
well 2006 what's the state of the web
today today we have evergreen browsers
we have html5 which arguably now is more
of a marketing term than a technical
term but it's really hard to not upgrade
chrome when you restart it it's really
hard to not have the latest version of
Firefox or Safari or edge in all of the
places where we use browsers as soon as
they finish inventing the thing within
the next six weeks we're gonna have that
on every browser that we're working with
yeah Safari for Windows is dead
IE four point five for mac was awesome
and painful
yeah Safari is the new ie6 so you know
that'll be kind of interesting but these
browsers update automatically html5 HTML
is now a living standard and so all of
these features come in automatically
javascript is a living standard and so
we move forward we can take advantage of
the features that come today almost
universally across every browser
experience
so here's my pitch jQuery was great but
jQuery is old the web is different now
jQuery solved the problem that we had
yesterday the problem that we have today
is different probably we have muscle
memory built up where we're like I need
to solve a problem I need to oh let me
just pull in jQuery and let me do you
know dollar dot paren and now we're into
jQuery land that's interesting but we
probably don't need jQuery just to be
able to grab a dollar open print
probably we can do these things with
native browser tools any questions so
far
I'm totally gonna make BJ dizzy this is
gonna be fun okay so let's dig into what
is jQuery jQuery is for the most part
these four main functional groups we
have Ajax Dom manipulation event
handling and animation are there any
things that you do with jQuery that
aren't these four
oh yeah I printed out on toilet paper
and I use it no I'm just kidding
Ajax Dom manipulation event handling and
animation it made these really easy for
us back in 2006 and it gave us a really
elegant experience on these four topics
today all of these are much easier in
other places let's look at each one Ajax
can we build it well with anything that
we look at here there's that obvious
argument of build versus buy should I
pull in jQuery should I write my own
should I pull in a different library I
love this micro Jas site because there's
all kinds of really really tiny
libraries to do interesting things
jQuery is 2 Meg's gzipped and compressed
so competing with 2 Meg's let's look for
an ajax library and see if we can get
something smaller than 2 Meg's 1.8 k 4
point 2 k 3 point 5 k 0 point 6 k one of
the things that makes jQuery wonderful
is it's that great user experience one
of the things that makes it's painful is
it's 2 Meg's that's big so you might
want to just cruise through looking for
the feature that you want here on micro
J's calm go grab the micro library pull
in that library and you might get to
that goal a lot sooner
so as you grab these slides later click
on micro J's calm and you'll get
straight there so ajax ajax is built on
top of xml httprequest
that's kind of the object that makes
this happen and xml httprequest now is
built into every browser let's pull up
can I use and let's talk about XML HTTP
requests
can I use is a great site that will that
will highlight the particular feature
and what browser versions it supported
in so along the main line is the current
version of that particular browser and
if there are older versions or newer
versions that are also released
you know Canary versions or beta builds
then they'll be listed here too so I can
just kind of walk across this chart and
I can see oh yeah XML HTTP request to
support it everywhere except for upper a
mini sender when you use Opera Mini so
it'll even show ie11 that's the last
version supported by Microsoft and so
you can see you know all of the things
XML HTTP request is supported everywhere
XML HTTP request is great and XML HTTP
requests actually has a library that a
newer API called fetch and fetch is
promise based and fetch is also built in
to all the browsers if you're supporting
ie11
there's a quick polyfill that'll give
you a fetch API that just falls back to
XML HTTP requests and you know makes
that happen which was really elegant
so XML HTTP request is baked in back in
the day we used to need to try and
figure out if XML HTTP request was
defined and if it wasn't defined we had
to go instantiate the ActiveX control
that was XML HTTP request to and maybe
sometimes that wasn't defined so we had
there look at XML HTTP requests before
and we don't need to do that XML HTTP
request is now baked in we don't need to
do all of that gyration to get to it so
XML HTTP requests the Ajax library that
we can pull off now fits on a slide and
it's hard to you know kind of digest all
of this code at once but it fits on a
slide I pass in the method I pass in the
URL I might pass in a post data and I
pass in a callback it's going to go
create a new XML HTTP request passing
that you are
method it may post data I'm making the
assumption here that it's JSON data that
I'm sending off and so I'm also setting
the JSON accept and content-type headers
then once I'm done if I'm it ready state
for whatever that means and I've
succeeded then I'm going to call the
callback with my response text if all
you're doing is reaching for jQuery so
you can do dollar Ajax do this what's
really interesting is I have this Ajax
method and I'll just pull this into
Visual Studio code if I want to for
example add my authentication header
I can just customize that to add my
authorization details because this code
now sits in my library instead of jQuery
I don't have to figure out how to hack
into their API to add additional headers
I may want to add additional error
handling here
that's not a great API surface but we
understand now I can reach into this and
do all kinds of interesting things to
make that work for my business logic I
now have control over the Ajax function
any questions on Ajax so far yep
this JSON library yes let's go back to
can I use comm and let's ask for JSON
there's JSON it is built into every
library everywhere we used to pull it in
JSON too just in case we don't need to
do that anymore
that's a great question thank you
this is just trade JavaScript yes yep
stick it in a JSP file and run it stick
it in chrome developer tools ah
stick it in chrome developer tools right
here and you can run it that way too and
I'm not actually gonna run it because
I'd be kind of interesting but yeah
exactly it's just JavaScript
exactly what if I want to consider not
just 200 a success but anything less
than 400 to be a success oh that's not
code I can type in anything less than
400 is success so 201 301 302 you know
ideally fit the xmlhttprequest has
already resolved the two owe ones and
the are the 300 ones in the three rotis
but yes I can reach into all kinds of
interesting things and do interesting
logic there I control this code yeah
stick it in your utility library
somewhere and you're all set
so Ajax we've kind of solved Ajax let's
talk about Dom manipulation well the
first part of dominate relation is dumb
selection and we can pull up can I use
again and look at document dot get
element by ID and see that that's been
in the native browser spec for quite
some time
all html5 browsers support document dot
get element by ID and what's really cool
jQuery kind of invented this of passing
in CSS selectors into a selection engine
to be able to get the results there too
we now have document query selector all
where we can do exactly that I can do
really funky CSS selectors I can pass
them to document query selector all and
it will return to me an array of
matching Dom elements so if you're
reaching for jQuery just so you can
select stuff just use document query
selector all so one could do something
like this for dollar sign equals
document query selector all now I can do
stuff like
that is that look familiar
is that a familiar document query
selector all and document dot get
element by D are baked into the browser
and we can leverage them we no longer
need to reach for jQuery just to pick
things so when we're doing this we're
not just picking things but we're also
modifying things we really like add
class in a remove class you know that's
one of the ones that I reach for all the
time we have dot dot class list on all
the things in addition to class name
which is that full string we have class
list which is an array of those things
so now I can add and remove into this
array in the way that I would add and
remove any other array so I just add
some class over the top of this thing
and it just concatenates that to the
list not duplicating it if it already
exists I can do the same thing to remove
it and it will remove it out of that
list sticking it back on that Dom
element
we always go for that duck text method
in that dot HTML method which is really
cool we have inner HTML and text content
they can do exactly that as well and
it's just a property so we can go grab
the content out of an element or we can
set the content into an element too to
be able to manipulate the HTML and the
text in this way
any questions so far about dummy
depletion
has changed in the browser to make this
happen this was a the focus of this was
html5 when they said html5 is a thing
they said all browsers must have these
minimum features and going forward HTML
has kind of become this living standard
and so browsers are kind of pushing that
edge but any browser that was html5
compliant had these all of them are and
therefore we have that we have it in all
the browsers now that's a great question
yep yes
all of these property names are the same
in every browser where we used to have
some that used this name and some that
use that name they've all standardized
now there's now a HTML consortium that
also validates this and you know as
proposals come into place they have
various levels of these proposals
getting accepted that give us you know
validation in one browser or validation
in two browsers or you know a complete
set across all of them yep
that is a great question what about all
of those other methods sibling and
closest and next and previous this site
is you might not need jQuery comm and I
loved this site because you start out by
picking your Internet Explorer version I
wish there was a nun button here because
I'm like totally don't care but then
given an Internet Explorer version which
is you know the oldest browser I can now
flip through this and I can look for the
thing that I want to do so closest
sibling so in jQuery we say dot next the
next element sibling is that thing that
we can use in every browser so I can go
for oh is is pretty nice that's cool is
this class we can do this matches
function which is pretty cool usually
when I'm reaching for a jQuery function
and I'm like but but I just need this
jQuery thing to work I'll pull up you
you might not need jQuery calm and I'll
search for that JavaScript that jQuery
function and I'll go find the JavaScript
that makes that happen I really love
this site any other questions here yep
there was a bit of a security issue
where people get started serving scripts
tags into your values and so we were
told to use dot text but both of those
being the equivalent to the value is
there a way to get around them that is a
great question so I have something like
this
and that's the script that I have now
that's great
shame on the guy who typed that but
still this is a cross-site scripting
attack I'm trying to get this into the
Dom so that I can do something and I'm
probably not going to just alert I'm
probably gonna I don't know swipe your
session cookie or post data to your bank
on your behalf and transfer transfer all
your money off or log into you as
Facebook and post some interesting posts
to all your friends so I have this
string that is supposed to do malicious
stuff so I could do something like this
string template equals I want to say div
class equals make it pretty plus some
string plus and div and so my goal here
is to you know add that text together
with my other stuff and and that becomes
my template and I'm now gonna show this
and and now my UI looks awesome if my
string said hello Bob because my string
doesn't say hello Bob because my spring
says go execute this JavaScript what I'm
gonna do when I say VAR div equals
document dot get element by ID my div so
I'm going to go grab that div and I'm
going to say div dot inner HTML equals
template now what happened
boom I want to not do that I want to say
make this not execute that JavaScript I
want I don't want it to treat it like
markup I wanted to treat it like text so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
I'm not going to get my div I'm gonna go
get the make it pretty ID so I'm going
to presume that this is already in my
page somewhere I'm
need to show it that's okay but that
markup is already in my page and so
because of that I'm not going to use
template anymore and I'm going to say
because I'm using the text property then
the browser will correctly HTML encode
that and now I'll just have a bunch of
you know angle brackets on my page where
that you know hello name piece used to
be I've chosen to use this as text to
guard myself against that cross side
scripting attack jQuery makes it
something like this to say here's a
function that may take in some struts
and stuff and basically what they're
doing is they're saying that we just
built the text method in jQuery that's
cool maybe I need that text method maybe
I can just call inner text directly now
they're also going to do something like
this
so that I can do you know get the text
back out of if I don't pass it in you
might not need jQuery that's a great
question
what other questions do you have right
here
dot your text on so free gift out of
your text
it's assigning some string to it how do
we get what the text is at that point
like where it's jQuery right there it
returns it
great question how do I get the text
back out I just read the property mm-hmm
yeah
your teachers gonna be so mad at me
tomorrow sorry okay
so we've gotten content we've
manipulated it we've added classes and
roof classes yep good what's the
difference between inner text and text
content somebody did
a typo and should have used this
property everywhere shame on that guy
good thing that we have a peer review
thank you it's not called inner text
it's called text content good catch
text content I think let me go ask can I
use yep
text content yes text is definitely a
gentler method to get into this text
content yeah inner HTML and text content
it's like can you like at the very least
capitalize it consistently
yeah either do uppercase or camelcase or
you know do we do dashes or do we not do
dashes or we can go like this and we can
do both of them yes because standards
are awesome
oh of course why is it XML instead of
just HTTP requests well because when
Microsoft put together the thing to make
Outlook Web Access the HTML part of the
thing had already been code frozen but
the XML part wasn't so if they called it
XML HTTP request then they could get it
into the browser yeah oops
okay so we've changed the content and so
we could for example start looking at
something like this and we already coded
this which was really interesting if we
just set document dot query selector all
two dollar sign and then we can do
something like dollar go grab the thing
and then go loop through each of these
doing interesting things let's add a
class let's remove a class let's set
some text content into each one we're
starting to do that same thing that we
do with jQuery each instead of jQuery we
have an actual array and we just you
know for each through that array
so the next thing that we want to do is
we like that click event you know dollar
dot dollar paren dot click well it turns
out there's this browser event called
add event listener where we can pass in
the thing that we want to listen to like
click and so we can go do exactly what
we wanted to do before so we really like
that
click methodology let's build a click
function and I'm going to take in an
element and a function element dot add
event listener
I just bought myself a click function
well let's do that so I have this click
function and it's just going to take in
some element and some function and by a
wire up the click event handler and so
now it's not quite the same experience
as jQuery because I'm passing in that
get element by ID result that actual
element but I'm getting that same kind
of you know jQuery ish kind of feel
without that to Meg download
so I've got the events and that's
interesting but I really like this I
really like how jQuery binds this in an
interesting way and I really want this
this this this as opposed to the other
this is so I like this so the way we we
accomplish this in jQuery in JavaScript
is we call function dot bind and pass in
to bind what this should be so the only
difference then in my click event
handler is I create this click function
and I pass in function dot bind element
and now the element is this and now I
can do this dot ID and this dot after
and you know all those interesting
things this dot class name rather than
just taking the function we're calling
function dot bind to set this correctly
so let's go rebuild jQuery we've kind of
got enough of these tools that we could
do interesting things and try to try to
see if those fibery features that we
definitely reach for jQuery for because
it you know kind of makes sense for us
let's see if we can do those well we
really like that document queryselector
all setting that to the dollar sign and
then we like that click event handler so
I'm just going to stick that click on to
that dollar sign as well so I go stick
this in the top of my utility class and
then I'll say hey
let me go grab the things results dot
for each
item and now I wanted you I didn't got
click but that's not the way I built
this I want to say click item and now
I'm doing the the content that I I just
wired up a click event handler I
selected all the things and that feels
very jQuery ish I could do a similar
thing if I only want one I can say
go grab the thing I only want one result
and I'm gonna wire that up into my click
event handler not quite jQuery but
really close and the code to pull that
off was four lines compared to two Meg's
that's interesting
so the next step is we may want to stick
on that Ajax function so you know I'm
just going to take that dollar dot Ajax
and I'm going to sign it to that
function that we built method URL data
callback now I kind of like that I take
in and arguments instead so I'm going to
take this Ajax function and I'm going to
stick it in our library and I'm gonna
say instead of just calling it method
URL data and callback
I'll just take in args and so args dot
URL args method and I may say and if you
don't pass it in its get args dot body
and then this is args dot success so now
we've got Ajax in our library any
questions so far
but but I really want it to be this
dollar dot and then go click and do the
things okay so let's take it to the next
level so here's that function that will
take in a selection and we're going to
go wire up some cool events to this
selection so that jQuery can do some
things Auto magically so let's go first
grab our batches and we'll do the for
each around those matches and we'll say
for each thing let's wire up an on
method let's wire up a click method an
add class method or remove class method
here we've got the text and HTML method
and so ultimately what we're returning
down here at the bottom is this array of
all of the things that are wired up to
do all of this stuff and in our
application if we also need on blur and
on focus then we can you know rig up
focus and blur events or the interesting
thing with this on event is it's just
going to get passed in whatever event
you want it to so you could use on click
and then wire up click event handlers
that way if all you need is that much
that's jQuery and it has an identical
look and feel here's our Ajax library
and we did all of the things that we you
know just sticky down on dollar Ajax and
we've kind of built up this Ajax clone
any questions so far
yep they just convinced their library
why don't they just condense their
library good call
yes exactly
it supports really really old browsers
jQuery one supports ie6 and if ever they
stop supporting ie6 that would be a
breaking change jQuery 2 dropped support
for ie6 but supports IE 8 jQuery 3
hopefully they'll take it a bit farther
I hear they're spec'ing out jQuery 4
maybe they'll move more modern and you
know drop support for all things and at
that point maybe it could be as simple
as the library who built here right now
it's still 2 Meg's though and that's
after getting rid of ie6
so you know they've got a ways yep
what's the process
good call how do I know what browsers I
need to support and because of those
browsers how do I know what features I
can use ideally you look to something
like Google Analytics or a similar
platform where it can tell you the
browser's of your users and based on
those browser selections you know that
hey if we stop supporting ie6 we're
going to lose 0.5% of our users 0.5% of
our users relates to this much of our
sales and so we're going to lose $20,000
in sales next year if we stop supporting
ie6 maybe our business can handle that
maybe a can't maybe we look at the
analytics and we go 0.02 percent of our
users use ie6 if we stop supporting ie6
we will lose $20 what's our development
costs in supporting ie6 well it's
definitely more than $20 it's probably
more than $20,000 let's stop supporting
ie6
google analytics is great because Google
Analytics very specifically targets your
market in a really elegant way if you
want kind of more broad versions let me
see if I can find it in 28 seconds or
less
can I use has a really interesting table
of usage statistics and this is you know
them harvesting usage statistics across
the world and there are interesting NPM
packages that are based on this can I
use that that will pull in interesting
things and I'm completely browser list
there we go so I can say inside browser
list I would like to support the last
one version and browsers that are more
than one percent of the global market
and that will cap that off at that
version and so I can you know do some
really interesting things there browser
list is cool and there's another site
that lets me explore what browsers
relate to this that the name has escaped
me I'm gonna remember it on the way home
today though it's ultimately what
browsers can I support ideally that's
less of a technical decision and more of
a business decision let's look at our
market share and the impact to our
customer base if we stop supporting that
browser so if I stop supporting the
browser what features can I use now or
what features do I need to not use and
that's where we go look at can I use
we've been using var today which is es5
can I use let unconstant
well how about fetch can I use fetch and
so I'll do exactly this I'll come poke
into all of these as I find a new API
that I like I'll come - can I use and
I'll plug that feature in and I'll say
so based on my usage statistics and what
browsers that I think that I'll support
can I use this feature yet can I use sv
sv n SVG yep can I use canvas can I use
for each can I use a raid sort come ask
can I use and that will help you make
that determination
what are these questions do you have so
far
awesome so jQuery is four things jQuery
is Dom manipulation jQuery is Ajax
jQuery is and animation and we haven't
talked about animation yet what's up
with animation post jQuery I have this
show in this hide thing going and I have
this you know open and and it's a nice
fade and animation animation is cool
back in 2006 when we wanted to do this
the way we did this is we set up a timer
and we said okay every 100 milliseconds
move it a little bit more 100
milliseconds more remove it well now
it's a little bit jackie well how about
every 10 milliseconds oh I'll make it
really smooth how about every 1
millisecond well how does that relate to
my screens refresh rate well it doesn't
so am i calculating frames that the
browser is just ignoring or am I not
calculating enough frames and now my
animation looks choppy so now we have a
new API that is requestanimationframe
and this is baked into all browsers as
well let's go check can I use because
you know it's a thing so
requestanimationframe is even in IE 11
which is wonderful whenever the browser
is ready to display another frame it
will call requestanimationframe I'll do
my calculation I'll be able to show it
what happened and at that point now it's
showing the animation as fast as I can
possibly see it jQuery doesn't use
requestanimationframe under the hood
jQuery 3 may but you know for backwards
compatibility it couldn't if I want to
do animation and I want to make it
performant requestanimationframe that's
definitely the way to go and so we
should move away from using jQuery for
those types of things and use
requestanimationframe well I really like
show
and hide well here's a CSS class that
gives me show and hide and it just
happens to have a transition so I've got
css3 animations here which is really
cool keyframe animation so I just add
the show class and I remove the hide
class and I get that fade in effect
that's cool if you just want to hide
hide is just setting the style dot
display to none show is removing the
none and it goes back to wherever you
need it to be so you could set it to
block you could set it to inline inline
block and that will show it so if you
want to take animation a bit farther
probably you want to look for our
framework green sock and animate dot CSS
are great CSS animation libraries that
will give you access to really rich
JavaScript API s as well where I can say
kick off this CSS animation and when it
finishes call my callback or let me
interrupt it or let me do interesting
things both of them are great api's they
definitely have a very different API
surface than jQuery but they'll give you
modern really smooth animations
ultimately as we look towards these
animation things we're also looking
towards other frameworks and we'll land
on something like this angular react
view or aralia
we're probably fighting over react in
view right now
angular 6 is definitely a thing and
aralia is really awesome they really
embrace web standards and really try to
get the framework to fade away from you
which is wonderful if you're leveraging
one of these component libraries you
probably have an animation system built
into that as well you probably also have
a text templating engine and so you
don't need to do that you know raw inner
HTML and text content thing as you're
leveraging these libraries you may also
have an AJAX library angular has very
specifically leaned on rxjs for this
react has one built in and view has one
built in
irelia says hey there's this King thing
in browsers called fetch go fetch
and so that's really cool too as you're
moving in this direction these libraries
probably will have a lot more
interesting things for you yep
good question so we have some JavaScript
frameworks here which one is the best
what size is the perfect coffee mug each
of these libraries has different
preferences different opinions different
strengths and weaknesses and I would
invite you to try out many of them and
find which one best matches your needs
and your skills and best matches the
problem that you have if you don't have
the problem that angular solves don't
use angular if you don't have the
problem that react solves don't use
react ultimately compare angular in
react and view and get comfortable with
the one that you like the best or walk
into your team and say angular view and
react and somebody's going to talk to
you for an hour and a half about why
that's exactly their favorite tool and I
agree for your team that one is the
perfect choice what is the best
framework the best framework is the one
that makes you happy the one that makes
you productive my best framework may or
may not be your best framework and
that's okay
does that answer your question what are
your questions do you have so far
yep
promises good question can I use
promises can I use promise yes I can
into all evergreen browsers promises are
built in what's really cool is promises
then become the foundation for things
like service workers and the fetch API
and so anything that supports fetch API
and service workers which by the way is
all of them will support promises as
well
so how about async and await all of them
you can use async and await in
production on your real site today
unless you're selling to those guys in
China that use XP with Internet Explorer
8 yep I wish I was kidding
[Music]
yes yeah you can do some really cool
things in the niche markets where they
have very specific and eclectic browser
habits
I've been dissing on Opera Mini a little
bit but in some markets Opera Mini is
perfect because what Opera Mini does is
it downloads the content to their
servers minify zit and then sends it to
your browser that can be wonderful if
you have a 2g connection and you pump
your own water the next billion users
may use Opera Mini and if that's the
market that you're catering for exactly
go after Opera Mini and understand both
the costs of development involved and
also the benefits to your business if
you're building a platform as a service
of modern cloud app probably that's less
important
what other questions do you have so far
yep that's kind of an interesting rule
of thumb I like that if the project
lasts more than a few weeks then jQuery
may not be a great choice and maybe you
want to lean on one of these frameworks
I like that where is that magic cut off
I look at the durability of the project
you know is the goal to like deliver
fast and throw it away in a week you
know a really quick marketing site or is
the goal for this application to sit in
an enterprise for a few years
what's the skill level of the team that
I'm working on also what's the
complexity of the thing do I just need
that submit button to work or do I need
to do a whole lot of animation around
making that submit button turn into this
animation and and reload the page in
interesting ways and ultimately you'll
get a feel for this you know you know
this was hard let's find an easier way
to do that let's lean on one of these
frameworks that'll do a lot of that for
us or wow we have a lot of frameworks
involved let's see if we can simplify it
by removing some of these frameworks did
that not answer your question yeah
that's cool complexity is kind of an
interesting thing to poke out there so
you've got it got good question so this
guy told us to get rid of jQuery
when is this a bad idea when do I not
want to do that thing well if I've got a
site that it has you know five or eight
ten years of labor built into building
this and it's built on jQuery you
probably don't want to spend five or
eight or ten years rebuilding that
without jQuery if your base framework
depends on jQuery then probably you
don't want to rip out jQuery angularjs
angular one depends on jQuery bootstrap
3 depends on jQuery underscore depends
on jQuery but angular 2 does not angular
6 doesn't
bootstrap for doesn't
underscore unfortunately is no longer a
thing so as you kind of upgrade your
stack then you can probably get away
from these what does underscore
underscore isn't one of the popular
frameworks right now underscore was
great in getting us past J queries
nested wing into kind of a more
framework II approach and then angular
came out and underscore kind of fell off
as a as a framework if I've got a modern
thing with bootstrap for and angular
material I probably don't need jQuery so
if we're in a highly regulated
environment and our code base is you
know a little bit crusty probably
removing jQuery isn't a good option as
well you know there are some industries
where it's like we need to ship exactly
this stuff we need very specific
validation of our application we need to
be able to prove that it works in all
the ways so the moment that you touch
that thing is the moment that we have to
retest it everything don't repent jQuery
out of that but the new content that you
build today you might be able to get
away with just a helper library maybe
dollar sign isn't the variable that you
craft for it or a few of these little
helper methods like click and text and
you know those types of things might
make your life a little bit easier and
you're moving in the right direction to
get to a more modern stack if you're
focusing on the WordPress type of thing
like I just need a marketing site and
your WordPress template uses jQuery yeah
it's probably not a good idea to rip out
jQuery out of your template maybe it
makes sense but probably it doesn't look
towards that cost benefit analysis how
much time is involved in yanking jQuery
out of my project versus how much
revenue will I gain from doing so if SEO
is really the killer feature of your
business and you really want to rank
high in Google having really fast page
load times and really light pages will
definitely help you
and so maybe removing jQuery will really
help maybe you'll get that much cost
savings by telling the boss that that
hero image in the top left corner that's
you know
five Meg's optimizing that image to be
500 K or 50 K might gain you that much
SEO benefit as well that was a great
question thanks what other questions do
we have so far so jQuery was really
elegant in solving our problems in 2006
today's browsers are different and we
might not need jQuery we looked at you
might not need jQuery com already that's
the site where I picked the IE version
and I could scroll down to the features
aisle frequently use that site to go say
but my muscle memory is doing this
what's the regular JavaScript way to do
that which one is my favorite yeah um
yes I do like working with them and
that's definitely my favorite of choice
ultimately I walk down through a couple
of things as I'm looking at which
framework I want to choose I look at
what are the cultural implications in my
business you know some people are like I
definitely won't use Microsoft or I must
use Microsoft I'll look at the team that
may take over for me and you know what
skills do they have do they have more
skills in this particular framework or
that particular framework I'll look at
what are the problems that I'm trying to
solve and which tools best match those
problems and then if all else is equal
in all of those then my preferences
start to take choice but ultimately
usually I'll hit one of these business
or technical answers before the
preference piece comes into play we have
a dotnet shop and so we're going to use
net or we have an angular shop and we
really like typescript okay let's build
this in angular or if I'm given a
problem where it's like just solved this
business problem now I can go look at
all the things and I can pick and that's
really fun too which one's my favorite
the one that accomplishes the job that
delivers value to my customer is the
fastest so you know this is kind of an
interesting meme in that direction
what if drivers were hired like
programmers I loved this blog post
that's really cool job requirements
professional
driving normal and heavy freight cars
buses and trucks trolley buses trains
subways tractors shovel diggers
contemporary light and heavy tanks
currently in use by NATO countries
skills in rally an extreme driving or a
plig Ettore Formula one driving
experience as a plus knowledge and
experience in repairing of piston and
rotor Wankel engines automatic and
manual transmissions ignition ignition
systems board computers ABS abd GPS and
car audio systems by world-known
manufacturers of liggett ori experience
with car painting and tin smithing tasks
as a plus the applicants must have
certifications by BMW General Motors and
Bosch but not older than two years
compensation 15 to 20 dollars an hour
depending on the interview result which
basically is every job posting
everywhere yeah
education requirements bachelor's degree
of Engineering at $20 an hour so that is
my pitch if the only reason that you are
reaching for jQuery is because it was
familiar you might do better and you can
save yourself the to Meg download
ultimately look to the framework that
makes you happy and really enjoy coding
this is a lot of fun to do thanks for
coming everybody
[Applause]